it's the western entrance into the
ancient city of oya it means new door
but it dates back thousands of years
oya was established by the phoenicians
nearly 3 000 years ago it then came
under roman control and flourished in
the second and third centuries a.d
it was conquered by the rashidun khalifa
and was renamed tripoli in the 7th
century
it's one of five unesco world heritage
sites in libya that are on its
endangered list
while it's been neglected in recent
decades that's starting to change
local authorities with the help of
residents have begun a renovation
campaign to save the old city
the old city is a symbol for all of
libya the city hasn't seen renovations
since the 1940s all the governments that
libya has seen since then neglected the
city it was on the verge of collapse but
thanks to the association and the
residents we're seeing new life put into
the heart of tripoli
the bab jadeed entrance has just
reopened to the public with a new look
and shop owners like ali mabrouk
couldn't be happier
before there weren't many customers but
after the renovations the market changed
new customers are coming in people are
visiting because they want to see the
new look
hadia
is on the board of directors of the old
city association and has been
supervising the renovation work she says
it's been her dream to breathe new life
into tripoli's old city yes i'm super
proud of course i mean it's something
uh
you know it's a dream coming true and
not even my dream my father used to work
in the in this organization my father
died i want to tell him you know i hope
he's looking you know saying okay see
you we've done what uh what you always
hoped so personally for me it's a it's a
yeah it's a big
it's a big thing i'm very proud you can
feel how the entire vial of the old city
has changed with these new renovations
and locals now have a sense of pride in
the city's rich history and a renewed
sense of hope that it could return to
its former glory naima used to live in
the old city she found out about the
renovations on social media
i brought my grandchildren to see their
history this change is amazing i hope
they run away the entire city 40 years
ago when i lived here the roads and
homes were falling apart this is a great
beginning libya has seen relative calm
since a nationwide ceasefire was signed
last october people here hope the
hard-won piece won't be short-lived so
the work can continue to maintain
libya's historical sites malak trina al
jazeera tripoli